like most of my generation i was brought
up believing in the american dream that
is the idea that working hard can help
you achieve anything you desire being a
highly gullible kid i developed a
conscience that viewed the american
dream as the quintessential pursuit but
although my conscience has controlled my
actions while growing up my opinions
have undergone a revolution i came to
understand that the idea of the american
dream has indoctrinated our belief
system and our thinking motifs in a very
devious way we became actors in an
involuntary rat race that urged us to
keep pursuing abstract concepts and
frivolous dreams dreams that were
usually imposed by others dreams that
were never really chosen by us you see
owning the concept of reality as this is
manifested in your everyday endeavors is
a very daunting task the required
struggle entailed in this process
becomes an unquestionable constituent of
what the evangelists of the american
dream would call a well-exercised life
the struggle becomes entangled into your
paradigm and you happily or unhappily
accept it as a necessity you end up
blindly following the rules of the game
and you become mesmerized by its
enchanting nature eventually forgetting
what this game is all about anyway but
does this always need to be this way i
remember when i watched tarantino's
hateful eights there was a scene that
really stood out for
bringing desperate me in their lives is
a good way to get yourself dead
you can't catch me sleeping i thought i
don't close my eyes i don't want to work
that hard no one said the job is
supposed to be easy no one said it won't
be that hard neither
upon watching this scene one doesn't
necessarily feel the need to analyze it
deeply but i decided to become a bit
more creative and add the symbolic
essence to it these two men are
archetypal figures the first one
represents the archetype of the hustler
that is the person promoting and no job
is easy the hustle is all there is
mentality the hustler is a go-getter he
will do whatever it takes to finish the
job and his reputation is predicated
upon his capacity to keep presenting the
hustle as the ultimate virtue the idea
of strategy and the adoption of
innovative practices that could ease the
burden of work sound nonsensical to him
hustle is what governs his logic and
different ideas are just distracting
noise the second one represents the
archetype of the contrarian there is the
person constantly challenging
conventional wisdom and being in the
search for innovative practices that
would revamp his mode of being the
contrarian is also a go-getter the
fundamental difference between him and
the hustler is that although hustle
should be a significant facet of his
philosophy it shouldn't be considered a
dogma a contrarian does whatever it
takes to adopt innovative methodologies
sail in uncharted waters and bend the
rules of dogmatic reality these two
archetypes are presented in this video
deliberately i wanted to find a lucid
way to argue about the proclivity of
modern humans to propagate the idea of
hard work as one of the ultimate human
virtues we glorify figures that are able
to showcase hardship in the way they
accomplish their tasks and whenever we
are presented with an idea of an
alternative we tend to dismiss it
especially in conservative circles this
seems to be the status quo however today
i want to pose another thought provoking
question what constitutes hardship in my
point of view hardship should be broken
down into two categories fake hardship
and valuable hardship fake hardship is
the one exhibited by figures pertaining
to the archetype of the hustler people
in that category use the idea of
hardship as a pathway to a more
favorable treatment for our tendency to
respect hardship will automatically urge
us to empathize with them essentially
fake hardship is synonymous with
emotional manipulation valuable hardship
on the other hand is not advertised by
anyone for valuable hardship constitutes
an imperative element of a well-examined
life whether this form of hardship will
be respected or admired is irrelevant
its purpose is to remind us of our
limitations and eventually help us
transcend the boundaries of our
capabilities drawing from these two
definitions we end up forming a more
canonical interpretation of the term
hardship and how this plays out across
the span of our lives revealing the
truth in that respect can offer insight
in the way one deals with hardship but
also in the way one deals with what many
would call its diametrically opposite
term indulgence indulgence is a very
interesting and often misunderstood word
its usage can be found in a plethora of
contexts and one can easily get confused
with regards to its proper definition
for the purposes of this video i will
make use of the word indulgence as a
synthesis of the words satisfaction
gratification and fulfillment these are
words that have always been of great
gravity to me and their pursuit has
defined to a large extent the way i live
my life the choice of the topic wasn't
coincidental in our modern epoch one
will unavoidably stumble upon writers
who will try to make a name by creating
guides like the art of doing the art of
work the art of hustle and similar
artful interpretations of the nature of
meaningful activities upon reading all
these titles a logical question arises
why isn't anyone discussing the art of
indulging what is so bad about
indulgence anyway that it has become
such a rarely discussed topic in my
opinion there is nothing bad about the
term itself the problem arises when
people tend to misinterpret the meaning
of words and also fail to see their true
value for instance oftentimes indulgence
is associated with debauchery that is
the excessive indulgence in sex alcohol
or drugs although all these forms of
pleasure are quite enchanting a moderate
immersion in them can lead to imbalance
and even lack of purpose thus having
them associated with indulgence
stigmatizes the significance of the
world this point is quite relevant since
one way to describe the good life would
be as the amalgamation of habits and
practices that can ensure a balanced
lifestyle we're constantly in the search
for the right combination of choices
that can offer us a way to balance out
the multitude of stimuli that include
our presence therefore balance seems to
be for now the most optimal way of
living in a world where the proper
understanding of the word indulgence
becomes self-evident one can reap easier
the benefits of a more effectual mode of
being a mode of being that is
characterized by intent awareness and
pragmatic strategy that will allow us to
abrade modern conundrums we all face
such a conundrum is the pursuit of
meaningful work work that is free from
oppression and becomes a way of living
rather than a way of surviving since the
beginning of the industrial revolution
this omnipresent conundrum has led to
the hypnosis of the modern worker and
their inability to think differently
specialization of labor has boosted
productivity but at the same time has
reduced the amount of indulgence
entailed in the work menial work became
the safe choice and our loss aversion
mechanism urged most people to gravitate
towards safety rather than pursue
different working patterns i want to
emphasize on the word menial here
because specialization as a general
concept doesn't necessarily act as a
hindrance to indulgence specialization
can offer the chance to immerse in deep
work which can be very satisfying in
itself insofar as one decides to
investigate the intent behind the work
of choice one can experience tremendous
joy in work even if it involves a great
degree of specialization after the
advent of the internet the concept of
meaningful work has gained steam since
more and more people have initiated the
fertilization of revolutionary
alternatives entrepreneurship has
transitioned from an endeavor associated
with the privileged view to an endeavor
associated with anyone creative enough
to disrupt different markets artists and
content creators have managed to
monetize their work and build followings
that could identify with their message
different working trajectories keep
emerging and people can change
specializations just by teaching
themselves new skills online in general
the opportunities keep rising and one
could say that eventually they will
become endless however plurality isn't
the answer to satisfaction people's
dissatisfaction is still palpable and
one could argue that most not only don't
feel better than before but also that
the average stress levels have increased
dramatically the reason is quite
self-evident the rat race has changed
only form not purpose everyone keeps
chasing a different version of the
american dream ignorant of the
ramifications that such a situation
begets indulgence is still either very
small or completely absent and that is
because most ignore it deliberately the
nature of work one does becomes
meaningful only when it provides the
necessary status that will result in
admiration from the rest of society the
creation of value becomes an ill-defined
idea and the notion of indulgence gets
lost in the translation of this idea
when bertrand russo introduced us to his
great essay in praise of idleness he
explained that idleness shouldn't be
treated as laziness but rather as a
critical idea that allows us to see
through the maladies of overproduction i
believe that indulgence needs to be
approached in the same light indulgence
is the antidote to the deleterious
effects of modern work that is solely
associated with toxic accomplishment an
accomplishment far greater than the one
limited within the confines of our
social mythology how many people do you
know of that immersing work just for the
sake of creativity or for the sake of
knowledge or for the sake of flow or for
the sake of presence or for the sake of
self-transcendence all these terms are
swallowed by the monolithic idea of work
as this was presented by the forefathers
of the american dream just imagine if
you for once would stop getting how
others perceive your work and focus on
everything that allows you to indulge in
the work itself everything from your
interaction with your colleagues to
finding solutions to seemingly insoluble
problems if this was the case just
imagine how most will focus on the
happiness and joy of life instead of
chasing delusions and fabricated
american dreams just imagine indulgence
isn't just a way to turn imagination
into reality but it is the way in and of
itself and we have been ignoring it in
this we have been foolish but there is
no reason to go on being foolish forever
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like subscribe
turn on notifications and comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it
if you want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon adrian out